[Musique]
je vais vous raconter un moment normal
de ma vie d'un chemin un anesthésiste je
me lève assez tôt le matin en général je
vais au travail à l'hôpital je retrouve
mes collègues nous échangeons nous
discutons nous travaillons et puis après
ma journée de boulot je vais faire une
pause
je vais aller prendre un verre avec des
amis certainement discuter de planche à
voile parce que c'est ma passion
alors maintenant je vais vous faire une
autre version complètement délirante
je me lève un matin assez tôt jusque là
rien d'anormal et je vais aller à
l'hôpital
et là je me retrouve de l'an devant
l'hôpital necker c'est là que j'ai
commencé ma carrière d'infirmière
beaucoup de souvenirs me reviennent et
je suis très ému je vais retrouver un
infirmier anesthésiste dans le service
de pédiatrie
nous échangeons il discute on nous
travaillons à leur association qu'ils
sont en train de mettre en place les
petits doudous de l'hôpital necker c'est
la 30e du modèle et la première c'est
moi qui les crée au chu de rennes
[Applaudissements]
je quitte l'hôpital et je me retrouve
dans une cour qui me rappelle vaguement
quelque chose je rentre dans un bâtiment
la déco est très chargé il ya un très
bel escalier sur ma gauche avancez un
peu je vais prendre un verre et sûrement
discuté de planche à voile jusque là
rien d'anormal sauf que là je discute
avec antoine albeau champion du monde en
titre de planche à voile
un peu plus loin je tape la discute avec
le président de la république puis la
ministre de la santé en fait
truc de dingue je suis à l'elysée
j'ai été invité à l'elysée pour le
projet les petits doudous le soir en
rentrant chez moi je me dis on en ferait
un film tu peux être que vous êtes déjà
dit ça que si on en faisait un film ce
serait pas du tout crédible c'est
effectivement ce que je me suis dit le
soir en me couchant
vous imaginez en quatre ans ce qui s'est
passé mais heureusement dès le lendemain
je reviens de très vite à ma réalité en
retrouvant les nouilles du self à
l'hôpital mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
quarante associations
en fait tout cela a commencé un soir
après ma journée de travail où je suis
rentré chez moi avec des cris d'enfants
plein la tête et j'ai envoyé un mail à
une société qui fabrique des doudous
moulin roty m'envoie un carton on donne
les yeux doux aux enfants à l'hôpital et
devant leur sourire c'est une évidence
pour moi j'embarque quelques collègues
et nous créons la première association
les petits doudous nous trouvons un
modèle économique en valorisant les
déchets d'aujourd'hui je pense un rosen
dans les poubelles de l'hôpital nous
recyclons les fils de bistouri
électrique pour le cuivre et les lames
d'intubation pour l'inox
nous avons trouvé un modèle économique
pour financer nos doudou pour aller plus
loin et mieux accompagner les enfants
les soignants les parents sur le
parcours opératoire nous imaginons un
jeu qui n'existait pas grâce à notre
réseau et un élan de solidarité nous
créons l'application le héros c'est toi
les enfants viennent au bloc opératoire
en jouant les parents les soignants tout
le monde participe
on se rend compte très vite que ça a un
effet très fort sur l'anxiété des
enfants et notre implication devient une
prescription médicale
nous faisons des études scientifiques
pour évaluer notre outil numérique nous
ont des publications dans les congrès
nous rencontrons d'autres collègues
d'autres établissements qui nous
interpelle comment faire un financement
participatif un peu plus tard et nous
définissons ensemble notre modèle
premièrement créé une association les
petits doudous dans votre établissement
deuxièmement fait du recyclage il faut
agir éco responsable et c'est en plus un
moyen de faire faire des économies à
votre établissement dans leur traitement
de ces déchets l'application on vous la
donne tous les soignants
nous rejoignent quarante associations
n'est plus de 300 aujourd'hui comment
garder le cap
comment garder le sens du projet et nos
valeurs en 2017 nous avons créé une
association les petits doudous une
association de national chaque
association est à sa place
elle a pour objectif évidemment
d'améliorer le mieux vivre des enfants
et des parents lors d'une intervention
chirurgicale mais aussi d'aider tous les
soignants qui le souhaitent à mettre ce
système en place dans leur établissement
et à nous rejoindre c'est un moyen
d'embarquer tout le monde dans le même
navire 40 associations 300 soignant la
vague déferle jusqu'en polynésie puis
nous nous dotons d'une entreprise
doudou développement elle nous ressemble
elles portent nos valeurs c'est une
entreprise solidaire d'utilité sociale
elle va permettre aux soignants de créer
les outils dont ils ont besoin
notre première application le héros
sétois agit sur le la médication des
enfants en diminuant la prémédication
cela a été possible car elle a été pensé
imaginé et créé avec et par des
soignants
c'est ce que nous voulons continuer à
faire alors je n'ai jamais imaginé qu'on
en serait là de mon mail envoyé
aujourd'hui ce projet c'est une montagne
ou plutôt plutôt un iceberg avec une
phase viennent bien visible mais aussi
une face cachée
comment faire comment garder le cap
garder les valeurs de notre projet en
fait je doute
en fait je doute tout le temps j'entends
je ne sais pas faire
ce n'est pas ton métier
ici tu n'y arrivaient pas et si tu te
trompes est et si ça marchait pas je
vois aussi le doute dans les yeux des
autres membres doudous des personnes
autour de moi
cela m'interpelle je dois aussi l'air
assuré j'entends aussi une vision
archaïque du modèle associatif est ce
qu'une association peut mener un tel
projet d'envergure et pourquoi pas à
lier associations et entreprises
il y a aussi des opportunités qui se
présentent
comment savoir quel chemin prendre
parfois cela serait peut-être plus
facile plus rapide mais est-ce que ça
garde le sens de notre projet et les
valeurs et l'engagement de tous puis
aussi du doute et de la fatigue
alors comment ne pas flancher
et bien moi je vais vous dire là vous
êtes tous bien assis dans vos sièges
et bien moi ce qui me tient c'est comme
une chaise et vous en avez tous aussi
sûrement une quelque part elle a quatre
pieds bien ancrés dans le sol mon
premier pied
c'est ma famille mes amis ils me
soutiennent
ils me font confiance il m'encourage ils
me comprennent parfois aussi ils
s'inquiètent pour moi mais il met
toujours avoir le soleil derrière les
nuages
le deuxième pilier
c'est mon travail j'ai envoyé un mail
parce que je voulais changer de boulot
et je n'y arrivais plus et aujourd'hui
c'est mon travail qui a changé avec ce
projet des petits doudous
ce bloc opératoire c'est mon refuge
mes collègues toujours et dans
bienveillant et puis surtout c'est ma
réalité
et quand je suis un dimanche de garde
tout seul au bloc opératoire et que je
vois un enfant arrivé au bloc avec sa
tablette et les outils que nous avons
mis en place à chaque fois
chaque fois je me dis rien pour lui
rennes pour lui ça valait la peine et un
autre de mes piliers de mes pieds c'est
les petits doutes ou ce projet
aujourd'hui il fait partie de ma vie et
surtout je vois dans les regards des 300
membres engagés soignants je vois
toujours le sens que nous voulons donner
un autre projet les valeurs qui nous lie
tous qui nous entraîne tous dans la même
direction
ils sont fort ingénieux tellement
engagée que c'est une vraie force
et puis mon dernier pieds c'est la
planche à voile
cela m'aide à prendre l'air du temps
pour moi à prendre du recul aussi et
surtout à prendre des vagues à surfer
parfois sur celle qui se présente à
prendre des risques à tomber à revenir
au bord
et puis surtout à repartir ça m'aide
aussi à ne pas perdre l'équilibré au
détriment d'un des piliers alors
j'entends je ne savais pas faire une
association
et pourtant je ne savais pas non plus
faire un jeu vidéo
et pourtant je ne savais pas faire une
entreprise
et pourtant
alors c'est sûrement parce c'est pas
parce qu'on ne sait pas le faire qu'il
faut pas le faire il faut bien essayer
pour y arriver et surtout nous n'avons
rien à perdre et tout à gagner
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes forts nous
sommes nombreux notre modèle est reconnu
alors je sais que rien ne pourra nous
arrêter pour améliorer le mieux vivre
des enfants et des parents à l'hôpital
tous ensemble ici vous avez des moments
de doute
peut-être que vous vous rappellerez que
vous trouverez votre chaise et vos
pilier finalement il n'y a pas de
problème à chaque fois c'était juste un
moyen d'affiner encore un peu plus notre
projet d'ajuster nos voiles mais surtout
de garder le cap merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]